aujourd'hui la france représente 1 % du
co2 mondiales 1%
c'est lié au fait que 90% gros de notre
et électricité décarbonés décarbonée si
elle nucléaire de temps donc c'est
complètement illogique pour des raisons
de dison électorale d'accord entre les
partis etc
c'est complètement illogique de fermer
des centrales
quand qu'on n'est pas sûr que ça va pas
relancer le co2 anna merkel l'a fait il
ya une quinzaine d'années pour pouvoir
s'allier aux écologistes demandent à
relancer le charbon en allemagne
donc bien sûr il faudra se passer du
nucléaire quand on pourra mais voilà un
exemple il faut remettre de la science
dans le débat et de l'objectivité alors
la prise de conscience vous vous en
parliez en europe elle est très forte
mais c'est pas là où ça se joue en fait
sauf le charbon allemand et polonais bon
mais le rsa se joue en inde en chine
soit ça et quand ils nous en continu aux
écoutes il disait plutôt vous êtes bien
gentil mais on a quand même des
centaines de millions de gens à sortir
de la pauvreté absolue
donc on a besoin de se développer alors
quand même dans ces sociétés
il ya des gens et des ong
des scientifiques qui commence à dire
faut essayer de concilier tous cas peut
tourner dans le même bateau et ça ça
fait partie de la bataille de
l'écologisation des 20 à 30 prochaines
années
mais on pourra pas le faire sur la base
des aspirations des gentils citadins
beaubourg d'europe
ils n'ont pas de réponses par rapport à
ces questions de l'ensemble des autres
pierre la question américaine aussi
[Musique]